so this is the actual graph that you've
got examples of
in your book okay on that sheet of paper
that i've given you
now what we want to consider is we know
how to graph this kind of thing
but we're not going to consider the
graph of this is the important part
we're just going to use it as a building
block and then transform it
map it to something else based on this
okay so therefore instead of saying
look my y-axis is going to be defined by
this
okay we just say we'll call this f we'll
define it as f
and then what you are going to draw will
be different kinds of it so we'll start
very simply
right let's have a look at this guy this
is about as simple as it gets
and you can even try to picture what's
going on right
the two approaches you're going to have
are algebraic
and visual okay algebraic is kind of
like a crutch
you don't want to rely on it because
very slow as you'll see in a second
here are my keys did you find them yeah
it's a very slow way to approach it but
you'll know exactly what it's looking
like and then you can use that sort of
as a means to
be more comfortable with just looking at
it and saying this is what it's going to
do
so let's look at this let's think about
this number one
in an algebraic way what does this mean
all it means is
minus well we already defined f of x
didn't we right
so it's two x plus three so here's my
graph
that's what i want to draw okay so if
you have a look at
your first on on the little sheet there
right i'll draw it up so that you can
see it on the ball
two x plus three you've got your
intercept up there at three and because
of the gradient
you're intersecting over here at
negative one and a half
okay so now when you compare this to
this
what's this going to look like have a
think about the features what do you
think's the most important feature that
you put on there straight away
y-intercept very good okay so that's a
negative three
reflected across this way right so
you're going to intersect
and because you've got a gradient that's
exactly opposite
to this right it's going to come down at
exactly the same angle that this comes
up
right so therefore you're getting this
kind of shape
okay so what's happened how would you
articulate in words
what this transformation has done to the
original graph
how'd you wear it
yeah fantastic okay so this is
reflection across
the x-axis okay
nice easy right now let's keep on
pushing on that
let's think about well how does this how
does this principle
work for instance if i wanted to reflect
it across the x-axis
this is what i would do what would i
have to change
in order to reflect it across the other
axis
so let's have a think about this
y equals f of negative x right
now can you see how this is similar but
just different enough that it's going to
have a different effect for us
right so this this negative over here
another way of thinking about it
is it modifies one like so
good morning so the reason why i place
that there
is so that you can see
reflection across the x-axis is a
perfect um technical way of describing
what's happening
but just visually i like to say that's
been flipped vertically
so when you think about it okay it's
being flipped vertically that's what i'm
modifying
right so therefore when you see this see
how the negative is modifying your x
value
well you can immediately say you can
instinctively say
i'm not going to be flipping vertically
anymore i'm going to be flipping
horizontally now let's just verify that
because we can use this
algebraic approach right so what does f
of negative x mean
if that's f of x what should i write
down on this next line
good um i'll just go one step before
that i'll just go to the the straight
substitution
which is 2 sorry 2 whatever right
2x u e to the x negative x whatever it
is
and then plus 3 okay which of course
gives you that negative 2x plus 3
that you were just telling me okay so
now when you graph this
against the original
okay 2x plus 3 was here minus 2x plus 3
okay think about it it's got the same
y-intercept so
there you are right but of course with
the gradient around
right just like we did before so this is
the shape that you've got
which as we just suggested as we just
proposed
is flipping horizontally
as opposed to flipping vertically
okay so the way i like to think about it
is
you've got this graph and it's behaving
in this in a particular way
right and then your transformation
modifies its behavior
it's still the same theme but it's just
been twisted around
in another direction right so you've got
your original features
there this value over here is going to
be important
one of the things that markers look for
is the critical features of the graph
not just the general shape
but that you know that this is exactly
the reflection of that
right and that's important that's one of
the reasons why on the graph you get
provided as
i've provided to you this morning um
they'll provide to you the scale
okay the scale is kind of like it's the
principle of giving someone enough room
to hang themselves
so you might think oh cool there's a
scale there that's nice of them
actually they make it harder for you
because you have to be precise
if they provide you the scale they
expect you to make sure that one and a
half
is on one and a half okay and there's a
reasonably
low threshold for error yes
okay so almost certainly um
in the hsc because they have sort of um
it all gets printed out and all that
kind of thing you will have to draw your
own one
and it will get scanned in and so on but
for us we're gonna we're probably gonna
provide you graphs
okay um just as a general rule the heart
of the graph becomes
like i'm giving you i'm giving you very
simple ones to begin with to illustrate
the concept
the harder it becomes the more we're
going to provide your graph so you don't
get hung up on
the original graph and so you can focus
on the transformation process
does that make sense